هنا في الصين ، أنت تبحث في واحد من
العديد من مواقع الاختبار الشامل التي تم
إنشاؤها بشكل خاص داخل بكين ، وهذا في
أعقاب اندلاع مجموعة المواد الغذائية بالجملة
الذي حدث منذ أكثر من أسبوع ،
سيقولون إنه الآن تحت السيطرة
لكنهم يواصلون الاختبار
بأعداد هائلة ولديك هنا 19
صفًا تم إعدادها لـ 19
مجتمعًا مختلفًا تتغذى على
موقع الاختبار الشامل هذا بمجرد تسجيل الأشخاص ،
يتم نقلهم عبر هذا الطريق الصغير
هنا في هذه السطور ودعوني
أريكم أين هم  في نهاية المطاف ، يبدو الأمر أشبه
بركوب متنزه ترفيهي ، حيث تصطف
في طابور هناك إذا كنت
ستظهر أنك تتبعني هنا ، وهذا هو
المكان الذي يتم فيه إجراء الاختبار الفعلي يستغرق
حوالي 30 ثانية ، ولديهم حوالي
مائة موظف  يعمل في
مناوبات مدتها ساعتان ، وهناك يقومون بعمل
مسحة من الحلق ثم يأخذون تلك العينة
ويضعونها في الثلاجة
ثم ينتقلون إلى الشخص التالي وعادة
ما يستغرق الأمر بضعة أيام فقط للحصول على
العلاج.  ترد النتائج ويتم إخطار معظم الأشخاص فقط
إذا كانت لديهم نتيجة إيجابية ،
يمكنك رؤيتها هنا حيث
سيقوم الموظفون بخلع جميع معدات الوقاية الشخصية الخاصة
بهم وسيرميها بعيدًا ويتم الاحتفاظ بها في منطقة
آمنة منفصلة
والموظفين الآخرين المستعدين للحضور في نوبة عمل
، يتم تغيير ملاءمهم
ويخضعون لإجراءات الصرف الصحي في
منشأة منفصلة ليواصلوا ذلك
من الساعة 9:00 صباحًا
حتى الساعة 10 مساءً في ثلاثة أيام
الوقت الذي كان يعمل
فيه هذا ، لقد أجروا حوالي 20000
اختبار تم إنشاؤه بين عشية وضحاها ، لذا فإنهم يظهرون
بسرعة نسبيًا وسيواصلون
العمل طالما أنهم بحاجة إلى
هنا في بكين ويقولون حتى الآن
إنهم يشعرون بأنهم "  نحن على طريق جيد في
إبقاء أحدث
تفشٍ للعنقود تحت السيطرة لكنهم
يقولون إن الرضا عن النفس هو ما
يحاولون تجنبه مع كل هذا David
Kaufer CNN Beijing